and it starts right here right now. We
have more Khan in a recent interview. He
also said the terrorist has nothing to
do with Islam. Watch this.
What he cites in the name of Islam and
all that that is not Islam at all. I
wish he would have somebody would have
put something in his head that these are
terrorists, these are criminals, these
folks have nothing to do with Islam. All
right, that's not all. Khan also
participated last week in an interview
with the Pakistani news channel Dunan
News. Now they're reporting quote that
he Khan said that Allah makes people
like Trump to make mistakes to discredit
them in public eyes forever. Really?
Here with reaction, the author of
Defating Jihad, the winnable war,
professor of strategy and irregular
warfare at the Institute of World
Politics, Dr. Sebastian Gorka, also the
author of The Complete Infidel's Guide
to Iran, director of Jihad Watch, Robert
Spencer, Dr. Gorka. Wait a minute. If
he's saying on the one hand that the
rules of Sharia, that those are the
rules to follow back in 1983, and then
he's saying that Sharia is not a, you
know, not what's practiced. What is
your, how do you deal with that
inconsistency?
Sean, we have to look at the facts. I
have no interest in attacking a gold
star father. Absolutely not. But he
became a political actor as soon as he
went to the DNC stage and attacked a
presidential candidate. Ju let's just
look at his statement. There's no such
thing as Sharia law. If he said that in
Saudi Arabia, he would be in big
trouble. The fact is, and Professor
Spencer knows this better than anybody
else, there are multiple schools of
Sharia law. Hanafi, Hanbali, Maliki,
Al-Shafi. These are the foundations of
the Islamic judicial system. To say it
doesn't exist is utterly fellacious. And
from a man who actually published on
these issues, it is more than just
disingenuous. Sean, okay, what is your
take, Robert Spencer?
Well, you know, he is being flagrantly
deceptive. Muhammad said war is deceit,
and I think Khan was listening. The fact
is that uh Mr. Gorka, Dr. Gorka is quite
right that there are established schools
of Sharia juristp prudence and also
there are Sharia states that are
avowedly following Islamic law which
they consider to be and loudly proclaim
to be the immutable and perfect law of
Allah. Saudi Arabia, Iran, Pakistan for
the most part, Sudan and others. And so
for him to say and they all it's worth
noting have remarkably similar character
because Sharia has a very particular
content and so they are all repressive
regimes that stone adulterers
thieves and do you think he was
purposely hiding his real views now
because he was so advanced in the
political narrative. Dr. Gorka.
I I can't search his soul, but but I do
think that it's very very strange that
he makes these kinds of statements that
don't comport with what he said earlier.
And this last one about Allah is making
Trump uh make mistakes. Imagine if
Tyrone Woods's mother or one of the
other Benghazi widows had said publicly
that Hillary Clinton is falling
downstairs because Jesus Christ is
making her do that. Could you imagine
the furori in the left-wing media? Could
you imagine? All right, I got to run
because we're just short on time here.
Thank you both for being with